كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخا باليستيا
وتتوعد واشنطن برد اعف الحكم على داعيه
تركي بالسجن لنحو 9000 سنه تونسيه يبيع
الكره التي سجل بها مارادونا هدفا بيده
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد ساعه قليله على تحرير من رد عسكري
اشجع عنفا على الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
الاقليميين اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخا
باليستيا غير محدد باتجاه بحر اليابان في
احدث عمليه اطلاق لصاروخ الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي واوضح ان الصاروخ حلق لمسافه 240
كيلومترا الى ارتفاع 47 كلم بسرعه
فيما اتى هذا الاطلاق بعد اقل من ساعتين
على انتقاده وزيره خارجيه كوريا الشماليه
لقمه ثلاثيه عقدت بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان منتهمه هذه
الدول بتصعيد الازمه الامنيه في المنطقه
محكمه في مدينه اسطنبول بسجن الداعيه
التركيه المزيف عدنان اوكتار المعروف ايضا
باسم هارون يحيى مع 14 اخرين بالسجن
ثمانيه الاف
و658 عاما لكل منهم صحيفه ديلي صباحا
تركيا افادت بان الحكم جاء بعد ادانه
المتهمين بارتكاب جرائم عداف منها التحرش
الجنسي بالاطفال والاغتصاب وحرمان
والاشخاص من الحريه بطريقه غير قانونيه
واستغلال المعتقدات الدينيه وانتهاك
الخصوصيه وغيرها من الجرائم فيما كانت
الشرطه اعتقلت اقطار وحراسه عام 2018
بتهمه تشكيل عصابه اجراميه تقوم على
الاحتلال والاعتداءات الجنسيه
الى مصر هذه المره حيث لقب قصه وفاء وهي
لقد تفاعلا واسعا على السوشيال ميديا
لتبرعها بثلوث الكبدها لتنقذ حياه زوجها
بعد تدهور حالته الصحيه اثر تعرضه للتليف
واورام بالكبد تقارير محليه نقلت عن
المعلمه هبه الجوهري قولها ان زوجها بدا
رحلته في البحث عن متبرع بين اقاربه ولكنه
اصطدم برفض الجميع مضيفه انها وعلى الفور
عرضت عليه التبرع لكنه رفض خشيه حدوث
مكروه لهما سويا الا انها نجحت في اقناعه
لاحقا بعدما جاءت نتيجه الفحوصات متطابقه
مسيره الى ان العمليه تمت بنجاح وتحسنت
حالته الصحيه
في مزاد علني اقيم بلندن بيعه الكره التي
سجل بها مارادونا هدفا بيده في ربع نهائي
كاس العالم عام 86 ضد انجلترا بيعت بنحو
مليونين و400 الف دولار وسائل اعلام اوضحت
ان هذه الكره كانت مملوكه لحكم المباراه
التونسيه علي بن ناصر والذي احتفظ بها
لنحو 36 عاما في منزله الى ان فكر ببيعها
مؤخرا تزامنا مع بدء بطوله كاس العالم في
قطر فيما توقع مراقبنا ان تباع كره اديداس
استيكه البيضاء اللون بقيمه ثلاثه ملايين
و600,000 دولار
هو في خبرنا الاخير اكد عنق تجاره
الالكترونيه امازون ان تصريح العمال قد
بدا وذلك بعد يومين من اعلان مواقع متعدده
ان شركه تعتزم مفصل حول 10,000 موظف هذا
الاسبوع ايضا في الخبر افادت التقارير بان
امازون بدات في تقليص حجم الوظائف بدءا من
قسم الاجهزه والخدمات دون الاشاره الى عدد
الموظفين الذين تم تسريحهم فيما قالت
الناطقه باسم الشركه لسي ان ان هو بالنظر
للبيئه الاقتصاد الكلي الحاليه تقوم بعض
الفرق باجراء تعديلات مما يعني في بعض
الحالات ان بعض الوظائف لم تعد ضروريه في
امازون